Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now it is finally time *deep inhale* to do what must be done.
It is a brand new day, and it is a brand new dawn.
And with that comes... a new game.
I'm not looking forward to this experience and I know you guys weren't either.
In the past, I have told you guys that I have kept this save game for MONTHS.
The same game I have been building on for MONTHS.
Many multitudes of hours poured into one game.
And I've upgraded over and over throughout every update that's come out,
hoping and praying that it would not blow up my game.
And yet, with the most recent update--the machinery update--I can no longer keep my old game.
I would be missing out on too much of the environment that they've built in since those updates came out.
So with that said, I am going into this new game without any console commands.
I will not be cheating, because in the end of the day, cheating kinda cheapens the experience of the entire game.
And it'll just ruin it for me, and it'll ruin the fun for everybody.
So, I'm going to be diving back into this ocean...
Something something "symbolicism" about how this is gonna be.
Blah blah blah here we go!
(mimicking souls of the damned) Ahhh, blefff!
So...
Welcome back.
Now with this update, there's been a quite a number of things released.
Number one...
I just realized how defenseless I am.
I don't even have a knife.
I don't have a Bubble Butt.
I don't have my SeaMoth.
I don't have the Fuck-a-Duck.
I don't have the Fuck the Ocean.
I don't even have Karen on my side.
Well, I mean, I've got Karen. Karen's always gonna be there for me. Literally, I have no one but Karen
keepin' me company at night.
Her cold metal endoskeleton pressed up against--never mind.
So, as with most--WHOA 'KAY...
(laughing) I totally forgot. Oh, my God, I don't have an air tank.
(crying and laughing) I have no oxygen.
Oh, my God.
So, you guys don't need to worry too much.
I'm not gonna go through the meticulous process of starting completely from scratch.
I just wanted to start here so that you guys knew what my intentions were
and why I didn't seem to be in the same place that I was.
(Karen talking in background) Don't worry, I'm not gonna make you watch me meticulously pore through every single--
KAREN, I AM TALKING!
(Crying) I KNOW ABOUT THE AURORA!
(weird crying noise)
Oh, yes, we'll go watch the explosion, I know...
"Eat something?" Oh, God...
(Karen proceeds to not shut the fuck up)
Ugh, that's so many problems!
Oh, there's so many problems, I forgot.
(crying) I took it all for granted...
(still crying) I TOOK IT ALL FOR GRANTED!
(yeah, still crying) I'M LOST ALONE IN THE OCEAN AGAIN!
(hasn't stopped crying) OH, THERE'S MONSTERS...
(this is getting ridiculous) EVERYTHING WANTS TO KILL ME!
Oh, no, it's getting night, too.
(laughing) Oh, God. Oh, no, I can't even chase these fish down.
I NEVER thought that I would lose ANY of the AMAZING things that I had built.
The MONUMENTS that I had stood upon.
Even though some of them, of course, I used cheats to get.
But that's besides the point. Igno-ignore that.
D-don't criticize me. I-I know I'm bad.
This is gonna commemorate the start of the new game.
'Cause, man, is this a big deal.
(mimicking the awesome explosion) BUAHHH.
Coooool!
Heh heh hah.
(exasperated inhalation) Okay...
So, now, I'm going to get busy.
I need to build a habitat.
My first goal here is to build a habitat, and build the new mapping room,
because that does exist.
That is one of the new things that I don't know if I need to find something to get that--
GOD DAMN IT! I DON'T EVEN HAVE A SCANNER!
FuuUuuck!
Okay, but... one step at a time...
Building a habitat is literally my number one priority.
So I will be back as soon as that is done.
Welcome to the party, everybody.
It's gonna be a fun time.
(crying again for like the third time)
I don't know if it's better or worse that I know what's in the ocean.
Because I KNOW there are monsters in the ocean now.
(Karen complaining about oxygen)
And eventually I wanna get down to the lost river, which is, um... uh,
this new area that they're working on. It's not fully implemented apparently,
but it will be soon.
And, in there, there are monsters the likes of which you have never seen.
Wow, I--
I don't know how I survived that, but I did.
Oh, God, no. Oh, God, no!
(crying for the fourth time)
I'm--it's fine.
(It clearly isn't fine.)
It's fine, it's 100% fine.
(No, it's not.)
(Karen complaining about oxygen again) Ah, shut up, Karen!
(crying and laughing) I feel like a naked baby that was dumped in the ocean.
(That's a weird analogy.)
I have nothing to protect me!
I've got nothing!
(crying) NOTHING! I am alone and scared.
(still crying) Oh, God!
Oh, why does it have to be night?
God damn it, I always do this at night.
(more weird crying noises)
Another cool feature that they added that was very much needed.
Uh, was...
The...
Ability for creatures to respawn after they've been eaten.
Which they didn't do before.
I was not even 100% sure about that, but they definitely did not respawn before.
So...
Now I can eat to my hearts content without worrying about destroying the entire ecosystem.
Oh, and thank the Lord, IT'S DAYTIIIIIIIIME!
Ugh, finally.
Which is good and--AH FUCK, IT'S AFTER ME! HOLY SHIT, I CAN'T SWIM FAST! OH, FUCK.
(crying count: 5) Oh, I hate the ocean so much.
Ooooh, can I make this?
Can I--OHH, I CAN MAKE A SEAGLIDE!
Already, I'm making so much progress!
(laughing) I'm doing so much better than I did the first time I was here.
Good golly.
Put dat dere. (Put that there.)
Alright, so that's there.
Uh, put that there. Scanner there.
Habitat builder there.
It's like I never left!
It's like--
It's like my family never left me!
:'(
In the horrible explosion that I watched and celebrated!
(crying counter: 6) It's like none of my friends died there.
Oh, yeah, look at that, yeah.
Don't look where you're going, just look at that. Okay...
"Bioreactor," perfect!
Alright that's one of the--it's not new, it's been around, but that's definitely cool because now I can use that.
"Mobile Vehicle Bay," also good.
Can get my boys back.
Okay...
It's time to go!
Time to go... time to leave the nest already.
Ahh, fuck...
Ew, ew, eww, ahh, it pooped all over me!
(unintelligible noises of disgust)
Okay.
I'm going to...
(in response to monster noises) Eugh.
I'm gonna try to make my base in a relatively new location than where I was.
Um...
Whereas my other base was on the ship side of the kelp forest,
I'm gonna try to do this on the far side of the kelp forest more towards the kush zone.
Because that'll put me in a better position for where I need to be in the future.
And it'll create a little, y'know, difference, which would be nice.
The problem is I don't wanna leave the safety of the safe zone. (Duh)
One, because it's a resource haven, like, these safe zones are actually
very, very important for me to be nearby.
So, this is the, uh, the southern safe zone.
By the kelp forest.
Which is a place that I've scoured before, but
I also want to be at the cusp of a safe zone, a kelp forest, and this area to the south,
which is a little more interesting.
This is about where I wanted to be.
Hehe, branching off into the depths of nothing.
Yeah, I think this is exactly where I wanted to be.
I'll make it in the cusp of this, like, this alcove here.
This'll be, like, my little, my little--
Eh, I'll make it over here. It's a little easier for me to get to.
Nah, I like this. Kinda my home away from home.
The--the "underhome" is what I'll call it.
(That's not a thing.)
I won't call it that--I'm not gonna--
I'm actually--I regret calling that at all, it's--that's such a stupid name.
(in a dumb voice) Yeshh! It'shh beautifuuul!
Huzzah!
I made it. I did it.
Yeahh!
Ffff--I forgot to make GLASS!
God--oh, God, and it's night. Ah, shit.
Ah, fuck, dude.
And my Seaglide ran out of batteries...
(awkward silence)
(silently) Fuck.
(slightly louder) Fuck.
(quietly) Fuck.
(quiet and high-pitched) Fuck.
(singing badly) ♫ Here we go again, back into the ocean, hope I'm going the right way ♫
♫ Don't know if that is true, I'm really fucked ♫
♫ If I'm going wrong it's gonna be bad ♫
(crying and singing) ♫ If I'm going into the dark ♫
(crying counter: 7) Ah, God!
Y'know... y'know the megalodon.
Um...
The giant shark from way pre--we hope from way prehistoric era.
Whenever I go blindly into the darkness, I can't help but think that I am going to be swimming along,
And then... I'm just gonna see teeth... and that's gonna be the end of me.
Like that's--like it's--it's possible!
(laughing) I hate the ocean so much!
Oh, good, just in time for day.
I'm glad I made that round trip in the night.
Boy, that was fun.
Oh, there's no power in here. Fuuuck.
(frustrated and/or constipated sounds)
Can I make it?
Yes, I can.
All right, here we go.
(laughing) One lonely solar panel.
'Cause hopefully after this I'm gonna have a bioreactor, which I think I actually have the blueprints for.
Or at least it's nearby.
Which is nice.
I'll take this.
Oh, is that lithium?
Ha ha heh.
Hot damn, thanks, Karen!
Boy, it's good to hear your voice again.
Okay...
AHHHH!
Oh, my God.
I don't know what it is about this game that makes me so stressed.
Somethin' about the ocean--
Why can't I make a--
Where's the fabrica--
Where is the fa--
There it is. I was about to say--I was gonna be like:
"Girl, I made Goddamn sure I had that in line"
(laughing) "It better not fuck with me."
Okay... there we go.
Got my fabricator. We don't have a lot of power, admittedly.
But at least I HAVE a fabricator here.
With which that I can start building ♫ from the bottom of the ocean ♫
And just as one new thing, from this, before I do anything else.
I want to go get the other blueprint for the bioreactor.
And I am going to build that.
There we go. "Bioreactor," that was it.
A-ha.
Okay, I have unlocked the bioreactor.
So let's see what we need for the bioreactor.
I don't know.
Oh!
I thought I had lube. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Oh, I had lube. (Sure you did.)
What happened to my lube?
Quaker Steak & Lube™!
AND LUBE!
(in a dumb voice) Ah, fuck, I think he was right on top of me.
I'm pretty sure (unintelligible) on top of his head.
Urhh, I think that was him.
(in a quiet voice) Fuck.
Oh, I have that. I have that in here.
I put it in here for storage.
Boink, boink, boink.
And, bl--Ooh, right in the center, hot tits.
Can I rotate that? Apparently not.
This is one of the new things!
It--it's not new but it's--it's working now, apparently.
Cool!
Oh, okay, so all I need to do, I put biological material in here...
Fish n' stuff, which is awfully mean.
But If I just put these...
In here...
It will...
(laughing) Grind them into a fine powder.
And then convert it into power.
How about that?
It'll even work at night, which is something that I haven't had for a while, so...
Goody goody gumdrops.
Whoa, oh, I'm--I'm close. (That's what she said.)
Oooh, I'm close to a, um...
I-I'm close to a, uh...
(Spit it out, man.)
Piece of the Aurora. I didn't even know I was this close to one.
Oooh.
I bet... that this--
Oh, no, modification sta-- (sharp inhalation)
What was that?
Oh, I forgot about you!
Urrgh!
Oh, God, okay, y'know what? Forget that.
Fuck you and fuck ever--AHHH HAH HAAA!
I just want the--fuck you!
AHHH!
AHH, fuck you!
Fuck you, man.
Oh, God, I'm outta batteries!? Fuck my life!
(crying counter: 8)
All right, guys. Guess who's back.
It is...
My family, the only family I've ever known at the crack of dawn.
(weird noise)
Hehe, it's--
It's my boys!
(laughing) Any day now they're gonna pop out.
This was supposed to be more climactic than this, but hang on just a second.
BOOM!
Where are they?
There they are!
Geoffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Ma-arshall?
Marshall was almost not there for a second. (Another dimension)
Geoffrey, Billy, Samwise, and Marshall, how have you been?
I know, I know...
Holy crap.
Why is this no working?
Uhhh...
Umm...
Uh...
I was under the assumption that there was s'posed to be a menu poppin' up at any moment there.
*Boink* Umm...
We--
Uh, it--
(noises of confusion)
(more noises)
Maybe because I have absolutely no blueprints for it and I can't even make the SeaMoth.
And I don't have that yet.
But I'll get that, but the most important thing is it's a brand new day.
Geoffrey, Billy, Samwise, AND Marshall are back.
And I made a lot of progress; I've been playing for about an hour and a half here, but...
I've been doing okay...
Gettin' by, and we're gonna get there. In the next episode,
I will be MUCH farther along.
I will explore much more things.
And I will be ready to build a Cyclops.
Not just a SeaMoth; I'm gonna get the SeaMoth, and then I'm gonna build a Cyclops
for you at the start of the next episode.
Have lockers for names.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
It's a brand new game, which means brand new possibilities,
And we'll be ready for new updates!
The ocean is a terrifying place, don't go there.
So thank you everybody again, and as always I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye!
[Outro Music]